nevada's attorney general is criticizing  a letter from a county gop  chairman that said president trump would  serve four more years in office chris  zimmerman the chairman of the nye county  republican party  said in a letter posted on the twitter  website that this would be a new 1776  and quoted some debunked conspiracy  theories circling online  now today he backtracked a little bit  saying quote we told nobody to rise up  he went on to say it was not intended  for a national audience and he did not  mean to imply sedition  meantime nevada attorney general aaron  ford a democrat released a statement  about that letter saying quote those  peddling conspiracy theories and lies  must take personal responsibility for  their words  and the consequences of pushing these  lies on a public looking for guidance  this includes the leader of a local  political organization